welcome everyone uh this is uh conrad uh
i'm the co-chair of the pi data global
2021 conference
uh we're very
happy today to welcome plan to come talk
to us about uh documenting your
scientific project with markdown sphinx
and read the docs and with that uh
i'll
let on you to get away for the workshop
thanks guys all right so before that a
bit of an introduction
of myself so my name is juan luis i'm an
aerospace engineer and i
self
talks
i'm a self-taught pythonista from spain
at the moment working as developer
advocate
at read the docs which is a hosting
document hosting company for
documentation
i'm very involved with the
python community in spain so i'm a
founding member i'm former president of
the python espana non-profits
association
and i organized all the seven in-person
editions of pycon spain and i retired
right
before the pandemic came
so
let's win
i've been contributing to many
scientific python projects so i have
some early contributions to sci-fi and
created some contentforge packages
i'm a core developer of astrophy as well
and some others and i'm also teaching
python for big data and data science in
a couple of private universities here in
in spain
okay so first of all what is
sphinx and i don't know if i see
reactions here hopefully yes
may
may you raise your hands virtually if
you have already used sphinx
for documentation
let me see
four people
five six
okay so
there's one person that said no directly
and wow how many people are here
um okay so there's a number of people
that have already used it
um okay so sphinx
according to its own documentation is a
tool that makes it easy to create
intelligent and beautiful documentation
you have the website here
and the way things works is by reading a
set of source files and then generating
some output
this source can be
written in restructure text markup which
is the default markdown which is the one
that we're going to see before but they
can also be python source files jupyter
notebooks images and all of that
and the output can be html but also pdf
manual pages
for linux and unix epub
and many other things so in a way
sphinx is uh
is a static site generator maybe one of
the first static site generators
existing it's not
very
trendy these days but it's still alive
and kicking
so some of the interesting
functionalities of it is as i said that
it has multiple output formats what that
they call builders
it's very straightforward to introduce
cross references and automatic
hyperlinks
for several elements of the
documentation not only sections
documents headings and stuff like that
but also figures glossary terms
code objects and more
you define the structure using a tree of
documents
and
from there sphinx automatically
generates breadcrumbs navigation and
things like that
it numbers
figures and other objects automatically
it can highlight the syntax of
code source files and it's very
extensible there's a number of
extensions
developed by the community that you can
use and some of them are very popular
so our objective for today is to
document a very small python library and
that i created for the sphinx tutorial
that i
that i've been writing for the past
months that is already online
and that we also reused for our own
quick detox tutorial
and
and create our documentation pages uh
step by step so
the few of you that
or the the ones that want to follow
along
it's already a good moment to click here
because it's demo time i'm going to
share this link in the chat just in case
there we go
and
what i'm going to use is this
gitpod thing for those of you that don't
know it this gives me
a visual studio code interface with a
terminal and
web server and everything
all in the browser
which is super convenient so
this way i don't need to rely on my
local environment this time although i
have a backup in case everything breaks
and you know the demo effects that
things
uh tend to break and this is a one hour
and a half demo so it's likely that some
things
will break but i will try my best for
that not to happen
all right so i already have my vs code
interface
and let's see first what do we have here
so we have a readme
um
with just a couple of lines about the
project so nothing fancy here
this pipeline pipeline.thermal file
specifies the metadata of my python
library
which is supposed to be installed and
reused i'm a big fan of packaging
standards so i use the very latest
pep621
metadata specification for this and the
build backend is flit which is my
favorite we're going to add some extra
requirements here
and we have the logo nothing fancy and
we have the code itself so this is as i
said a tiny library it contains a custom
exception
and
a custom function that at the moment
returns a hard-coded list of strings
and so the idea of the library is that
it's supposed to help you create recipes
but at the moment these random
ingredients are very straightforward
okay so this is our
starting point
and
without further ado let's get started
so the first thing we're going to need
is to add sphinx
as our list of requirements
so for that i'm going to use the same
piperetal thomas or the same metadata
specification that i'm using um to
install the library itself
so i'm going to add here project
dot
optional dependencies
and then i'm going to specify an extra
family of dependencies that i will call
doc
and i will use sphinx
4.2.0
okay so this is going to be my sphinx
version by the way all the things that
i'm going to type if you're lost or you
want to catch up at some point or you're
doing late or whatever they're in this
notes dot md
file that you can find in the repository
itself
if i can zoom in sure
uh brandon i will do that
and it's the tomal file something that i
need to make by myself for my own
documentation so the tomal file is a way
of specifying the dependencies of the
python library and it's sort of the
modern replacement to setup.pi
setup.cfg that you might have seen in
the while out there
um
so yeah it applies to all python
libraries that you want to create
um
and
let me
increase my zoom a little bit hope that
is
better let me know otherwise
um okay so i have my optional
dependencies and now the cool thing is
that
here i have a python environment
so my python version
is 3.8
and i'm going to pip install
in editable mode
my project with this dock
extra
and
there's a chance that this doesn't work
so instead of running to that i'm going
to upgrade pip first
so python management install upgrade pip
so that's the first thing
keep your pip up to date
and
now let me peep install minus e
dots
and then the dock
dependencies so this is going to install
my small library lumake.pi and
it's also going to install sphinx and
all the transitive dependencies of
sphinx
there we go
so we already have it
and
if that's correct this means that we
should already have this sphinx
quickstart
command
let me check if there's things in the
chat i will be checking from time to
time
okay nothing else and feel free to
send questions in the chat i might not
be super fast to respond but i will do
my best
and
if you want to admit yourself and ask
something i'd be happy to answer as well
if it's something that you
we will see
later on in the tutorial then i will
postpone the question and that's it
okay
so we already have sphinx quick start
so this command is going to
generate the
basic structure of a sphinx
documentation project
and it receives one parameter which is
the directory where i'm going to have
all those files and i'm going to put it
in docs it's a good practice to have it
in a in its own directory
and now it's going to ask me a series of
questions this is very similar to cookie
cutter that you might have seen
somewhere else
and things like that
so first of all do i want to separate
the source and the build directories i
usually do this in all my projects even
if it's not the default i think it makes
everything cleaner so i'm going to say
y for yes
now the project name i will call it
lumake
and i'm going to type my own author name
i detected some
problems with the special characters
here i don't know why but unique is
nothing important
fortunately
now the project release i'm going to
write 0.1 anything works at this moment
and the project language is going to be
english so i can leave the default
and i'm done i'm going to display again
just in case the answers that i typed
for you to see
yeah that's it
so separate the source and put
directories the project name offer name
bracket version and project language
and this created a number of files that
we're going to explore now in a moment
maxim says i don't remember if you
mentioned but
why do you prefer sphinx
why do i prefer sphinx with respect to
other alternatives do you mean like mk
dogs docusaurus
p-dog
well sphynx is the oldest and probably
the most powerful documentation
generator
and i think now nktox is starting to add
like auto summaries auto lock
and cross references and things like
that these are very recent
but
sphinx is very solid it's used for the c
python documentation as well
and
it has a large
number of extensions so those would be
my reasons to
er to prefer that
ah hello rather one yes i i remember you
okay so let's see what
do we have here so we have a couple of
make files we're not going to
uh
pay much attention to them we're just
going to use them and the important
files are here inside the source
directory so we have our index dot rst
this is restarter text although we're
going to convert this to markdown in a
moment
and you can see here like some comments
this is a
first level heading this is the talk
tree which is the table of contents
three we're going to manipulate it
in a moment and then some extra
references here
so that is going to be the index
of my documentation site
and then very important i have a comfort
pi which is defined that holds all the
documentation sorry all the
configuration of
sphinx and we're going to make a number
of tweaks here you see it contains the
project copyright and so forth
also an empty list of extensions we're
going to add some of them and some other
options that we have here so this is
what
we have at this moment
and before going any further it's a good
moment to try to see if at least this
base extractor
already works
so i'm going to split the terminal here
with this fancy button that i have
on the right
i'm going to change the directory to
docs
and thanks to this make file i can type
make html and this is going to build the
html documentation
immediately you see well there's
things logs are quite verbose i'm not
going to analyze everything that we have
here but
what we can see is that we don't have
any red text which means that there are
no warnings or errors
and therefore everything
is more or less working at least
apparently
so
this generated a bunch of html files
here and what i'm going to do is to
serve them with
the built-in python http server so for
that i do python minus m http server
and this launches a web server on port
8000
and
[Music]
i would love gitpod to
tell me now that
it's about to okay yes it took a few
seconds but it works
so this gives me a bunch of options and
i'm going to open the browser here
you have to allow pop-ups for that
and this is my documentation site
so this is the one level the level one
heading
the extra references and some other
information so at least for the moment
this is working
okay so this is a very good moment to
commit my changes so for that i'm going
to use the source control view here on
the left
let's review what we have
so we added some extra dependencies here
for building our documentation in
particular sphinx 4.2
we also have a couple of make files here
that we're going to study in depth we
have our configuration
and our index page so this looks really
good
and i'm going to say
a basic
documentation
structure
yes i want to commit everything and yes
i want to synchronize my changes
aha well this is telling me that i don't
have access to that which is expected
so i'm going to create a fork
all right you you will probably
see a very similar prompt
so create fork
and do you want console to run git fetch
no
i don't care at this point
so it's still pushing the changes at
this point if it's the first time that
you use gitbot you will probably have to
like configure the integration and
things like that
okay so i already have my fork online
i'm
so happy that this worked first time
and you see that i have my docs
directory that i'm one comment ahead of
the main repository so
so far so good
okay
so
no more new questions in the chat
and
so let's continue
um
we're only
five minutes delayed
from my initial plans so we're doing
really really good okay so
this tutorial is called
a document your sphinx project with
markdown
but we have restructure text here
so
just a couple of words about this
restructure text is
probably one of the oldest
markup languages that still exists
it has very old roots
it's much older than markdown
in fact
and it's super powerful because it
allows you to define your own
roles and directives which is which are
custom blocks of syntax to do specific
tasks
and it allows you to do cross references
and export the documentation to several
tools and things like that so it's a
really powerful tool i'm mixing
here for the sake of simplicity
restructure text which is the markup
with doc utils which is the tool that
parses the markup the markup and does
all these things
however
um in recent years probably thanks to
the popularity of github and virtually
every other tool that uses markdown
and we see markdown everywhere we use it
in slack we use it in
github comments in the in readme files
and so forth
so
the idea is to try to bring
this
easy way of working and simplicity to
sphinx
and for that there's a kind of a new
project called missed parser
that does exactly that
so it defines a custom dialect of
markdown
that is
um
[Music]
compatible with docutels and contains
all these extension points that we know
and love
so we're going to convert this
documentation from
restructure text
to
markdown and for that i'm going to
install a little tool it's called
pip install
rst to mist with the extra requirements
sphinx
and this is going to give me a command
line tool to convert
this file into markdown so i'm going to
call it right now rst to
mist
and then i need to specify the command
convert
and
all the files that i want to convert so
i'm going to convert everything inside
any directory under docs
at the moment i only have one file but
this is a pretty standard
conversion tool
and it's succeeded so it converted
index.rst to index.md
and if i display them
side to side
you see that they're
basically the same
i'm going to move this here yes
so now we have these familiar headings
that we know from markdown this is a one
level one heading and again a level one
heading
and these two blocks here are these
extensions so these custom directives
and roles
that also work in mist with a slightly
different syntax
but they work in exactly the same way as
in restructured text
so now i'm going to say farewell to my
index.rst
i'm going to say here right click
delete permanently yes
so long and thanks for all the fish
and now i have my index page written in
markdown instead
but i need to do some extra stuff here
let's see i'm going to cancel my server
for a moment
and i'm going to
change directory to my documentation
source again if i now type make html i
will notice that this fails
because it tries to locate an index.rst
and there's none basically because i
removed it
so what i'm going to do is to enable
an extension that allows things to load
markdown instead so for that i'm going
to come to conf.buy
and i'm going to add here missed
underscore parser
so this is my extension and before i can
use it i need to install it so now i'm
going to come to the terminal again and
i will do pip install
mist dash
parser
this installs a bunch of stuff luckily
very quick
and now if everything is correct i
should be able to do make html again
you see now i briefly see the output
there's no red text no warnings or
anything
so i'm going to go back to build html
and launch my dear http server again
which will open port
8000
okay and as you can see this is exactly
the same as i had before
so now my recommendation is written in
markdown but visually for the user there
is exactly zero difference
so i will call this a win
there's some comment in the chat
i cannot run the pip minus e it tells me
that it requires setup tools based yes
so
exactly so you had to upgrade pip this
was released
two weeks ago so i'm literally on the
bleeding edge
um
okay there are no more questions so it's
a good time to commit these
changes as well
um
so i'm going to go here again
and the changes are as you can see let's
review
so i added this missed parser extension
and
i added this index.md which is a
conversion from the other one and i
removed
index.rst so everything looks good to me
i'm going to set the message convert
docs to marked down
missed commit yes
synchronize the changes
and
[Music]
we're done
okay so time to make some
more progress
jeremy says what is the missed parser
for again so missed parser is the tool
that allows us to
write the documentation in markdown so
mist stands for markedly structured text
and it's a dialect of markdown that is
compatible with swings
and so missed parser enables sphinx to
load
dot md
files basically
all right
so let's continue
um i'm going to make some small tweaks
to my documentation just to see
if um
this works but before that you see this
workflow of
cancelling my server and then make html
and then launch it again and so forth is
going to become tedious very soon
so instead what i'm going to do i'm
going to cancel this thing
and i'm going to move upwards
i'm going to install
a very cool tool that is called sphinx
auto build so now i'm do beep install
sphinx auto build
which is created by one of the
maintainers of pip
pradium which is also the author of
sphinx theme that we're going to use
very soon
um and so this sphinx auto build
what it does for me is to monitor
changes in the dock
directory and
reload the server
and rebuild the sphinx documentation
every time there are changes so now i'm
going to launch sphinx dash auto build
and
on
the directory docs slash source
and my output directory will be docs
build html
so now i launch it
again it's telling me that there's a
server
so i need to open it again
what's going on
okay it took a few seconds uh but it's
here
and now every time i modify the
documentation this is going to be
automatically reloaded so i'm going to
get away with this because i rarely use
it it's going to add some visual noise
and i'm going to simplify this
heading here
and you see i removed this stuff and now
well if it doesn't reload automatically
you can like make some change to the
file to force
um a reload here yes now it says lumaki
only
i'm going to give you a trick
that many of you will appreciate you can
thank me later so you know i already
wrote
some documentation about the project
here in the readme so why not including
the readme in the documentation
and it turns out that with
mist this is really really easy so i'm
going to add a directive
called include this is the syntax for
directives okay so they come in triple
buttocks
and in braces they include the number of
sorry the name of the directive or
similar and i'm going to tell it to
include the
readme.md which is two directories above
and to keep
the
images
uh in order
and
i think i can remove this one this level
one heading now
and if i now see what is the result of
that
nice so you see i get the readme here so
i don't need to state it again like the
description of the project and
everything
and
finally i'm going to add a little note
that says that this library is still
under heavy development with the
admonitions that we know and love
so i'm going to open triple backticks
again
and open an admonition called warning
and then the content will be this
library is under heavy
development
okay so if i go back here you see i get
this
warning here
all right
there's some questions in the chat
great tutorial but can you also showcase
the code documentation yes not so fast
um give me 15 minutes or so
and
sims law got a little bit lost how did
you install the missed parser extension
i did beep install
missed parser
i think this should be in the notes but
there's a chance that i forgot
yes i forgot
so it's deep install
mist dash parser
thank you jeremy
okay so again it's a good moment to
commit
let's review what we have here
so
i
replaced this level one heading
with
including the readme so i don't repeat
myself
i added an admonition a warning
admonition
and i remove this extra information here
so i'm going to
say
add minor
edits
to
index commit
changes
and we're done
okay
so let's continue then now
we're going to see how we can customize
sphinx a little bit more
so
i'm going to go back to my conf.buy
i already enabled one extension here and
this is a third-party extension which
means that i both have to
install it
and
i also
um
have to add it here to the list of
extensions
by the way i'm realizing that i forgot
to add it to the requirements so i'm
going to do that right now
this is missed parser
and i'm going to add that to my commits
and declare
missed
parser as dependency
right
yes so i don't have problems later on
um i was saying that i added this third
party extension but sphinx has a number
of
built-in extensions so for example
there's a very simple one sphinx dot x
dot duration
which gives me in the output of the
build
how much time did it take to build each
of the documents so you see now i have
this extra information here and this can
come very handy
for
certain workflows
and these extensions apart from
modifying the behavior of sphinx itself
allow me to
customize the output as well
so for example i'm going to add
another extension that allows me to
change the theme the current html theme
that you see here is alabaster which is
the default theme theme and has been the
default for a long time
but to my taste there are now more
modern options to it and in particular
i'm going to declare here a dependency
on furo
which is the name of the theme
i'm going to pip
install
furor
so as a third party extension i also
have to install it
and finally i'm going to change the html
configuration from alabaster to
euro
so now when i come here
i get this new theme and
well there's lots of cool things about
furo but
my favorite one probably without
anything else is that you can change
between dark theme
light theme or make it automatically
follow your
browser and operative system
configuration
so i think it's
easier to see if i leave the light theme
on the screen and everything
and so i'm going to leave the light
thing here
and there's a question about sphinx and
jupiter book that i think we can
answer at the end i'll be happy to
discuss about this because it's a little
bit long
okay so i modified my theme i added an
extra extension
so i'm going to commit my changes again
let me go to the source control view
let's review what we have
so i added one extra extension to my
optional dependencies
and
i enabled a built-in extension from
sphinx
and changed the html so this looks good
to me
and change theme to furor
and i sync my changes
and
errors
what happens
let me try again
okay
fault alarm
okay
so let's continue now
we're going to see how to add cross
references which as i said is one of the
strong selling points of sphinx
and for that i'm going to add some extra
content to my documentation you'll have
here in the notes but i'm going to type
it all along
so i'm going to come here and add a new
file that i'm going to call usage.md
the first thing we you will notice here
i'm going to pay some more attention to
the output now is that
sphinx gives me a warning because
usage.md doesn't belong to any
talk tree we're going to fix that in a
moment but this is an important warning
because it means that your users will
not be able to reach this document
there's no link pointing to it basically
so i'm going to add a title usage and it
will have one section which is
installation
so to install lumake
you can do this and i'm going to add a
code fence
console
and i'm going to
like give some installation instructions
right beep install market this doesn't
work but it
let's pretend
that
this library is already famous okay
so
this is how
my markdown looks like but i keep
getting this annoying warning here so
let's address that now
i'm going to split my screen so you can
see
this file on the right
and here well it's completely that usage
is not included in the talk tree so
let's add that to the top tree and the
way to do that
is
to include the name of the document here
and that's it
so
what this did
was to declare that usage is a child
document of index
and this is the first step towards
building our
three of documents
all right so now if i go to
my documentation you see that now i have
like a contents table
and
i see the headings here
so i go to usage and here the
instructions that i wrote before
all right
what do we have other other themes
for sphinx
yes
is things themes
there's this
wonderful gallery here
that i shared with you in the chat
so there's
alabaster which is the default read the
docs theme which is the one that we
developed for our sites furo which is
the one that we're using now book from
jupiter book the pi data fame and many
others okay so you can have a look there
may you also suggest some blog or some
good resources for practical sphinx
documentation yes let's get to that at
the end
um
okay so yes i added a document and now
it's part of the talk tree
but i can do much more so for example i
can generate a reference to the document
and notice that
if i navigate here the url is something
like i don't know weird subdomain
dot gitpod.io io
usage.html
so how do i generate a
link that is
robust against changes in the domain
name because the structure of the
documentation is going to be the same
so instead of hard coding the path like
that
i'm going to
use
one of these sphinx roles
so i'm going to say
for
further info check out and then i'm
going to add the doc
roll specifying that i'm generating
a link to the usage stock
and
again this is the syntax for roles in
mist and what this does is if i go back
now
you see to generate a link to the usage
so i can go back and forth between one
place and the other and this is
independent
uh from where the documentation is
hosted
all right
um
apart from generating links to the
document itself i can also generate a
link to a specific subsection
of the document so for example imagine
that i want to generate a link to this
installation part here
so the easiest way to do that this is
another trick
and we're going to enable another
extension here in the comfort pi
that is going to generate targets
for
every
subheading
in every document
so for that
i'm going to enable
the
sphinx
dot x
dot auto section label
[Music]
extension
and after i do that now here in index.md
i can say
read
installation instructions in
and then there's another role which is
ref
and here the
reference
is the name of the subheading you see so
this is
installation with capital i
and i use that here
and that means that if i go back to my
index now you see i have usage that goes
to the document
but i also have installation
that goes to this heading in particular
all right
so i'm generating two kinds of cross
references here
okay so i see there are no more
new questions in the chat so it's a good
moment
to commit again
let's see what
changes do we have
so i enabled one extra extension so i
can generate crash references to
subheadings
i added a couple of
um
cross references to several parts of my
documentation and
added usage to top three
and also i added this usage document
with some extra content so i'm going to
say
add usage
document
and cross references
commit
and sync
perfect
okay and now
um
we're going to see a couple of
very interesting things first we're
going to see how to integrate jupyter
notebooks which i hope is very useful
for the by data global audience
and right after that we're going to see
how to
automatically generate documentation
from my source code
and which is sometimes a little bit
tricky but i'm going to give some tips
so before that
let's get to the notebooks part and
luckily again this vs code has
a way of using notebooks
so i'm going to create a new folder here
called notebooks so i don't mix them
with the others
and inside of here i'm going to create a
new file
called
tutorial right so i'm going to write the
tutorial for my library in the form of a
jupyter notebook
vs code automatically detects
that
this is a jupiter notebook so it gives
me this preview here
let me see that's that
this works
it
tells me to choose the interpreter so
this is the python38 that i
want and
here's the zen of python coming in
there's a lot of new like servers uh
opening i don't know what this mean so
i'm going to close these notifications
very gently and ignore them because my
web server is still running on port 8000
so i don't care about the rest
okay so let's add some
silly content for a tutorial right i
need a heading
and
to make is very easy to use
import the function
right and now i'm going to say from
lumaki import get
random ingredients
and
call the function
right and now i get
another
python cell
doing
get random ingredients
that should give me a list of strings
and i say
don't speak in italian
for consistency
okay so this is the tutorial for my very
simple python library you see that every
time that i was modifying the notebook
as sphinx auto build is
um rebuilding and rebuilding again
the documentation
and however for the moment it's ignoring
the file so i don't see any warnings
here that
it's not
included in any talk tree or anything so
i need to
do some more work
thank you
roshana i don't know this video but
please share it in slack later on as
well so i can have a look because i
think this chat is lost after the call
okay so now what do we do how do we
include this notebook as documentation
so we need an extension again to do that
there's two that do this my favorite one
is nb sphinx
and you also have
missed
nb which does more or less the same
thing
and
since it's a third party extension i
also have to install it so let me
declare it
as the list of my dependencies now i
will do pip install
nb sphinx
now let me force a reload of the
documentation just check what is my
current status
notebook error ah pandoc wasn't found
okay so i need some more luckily here in
gitpod i can
sudo apt-get install pandock
this is used to convert to html
and all of these
instructions are also in the notes
and
the me force revealed of the
documentation again
okay so i guess
now the warning that i wanted the
document is not included in any talk
tree all right
which means that now sphinx is detecting
that this is a valid source file
but i need to do the same thing i did
before so i'm going to
tell things that
the tutorial is also a child
of
index
right optionally i could add a talk tree
to use it for example but i'm going to
keep everything in the index
no warnings here which means that now
i have my usage which is the same as
before but also
i have
my tutorial
you see and now this is like any other
documentation page with its headings and
everything but all the code cells are
highlighted with the jupiter
um
a color scheme
and all the outputs are included and
everything
so this is a very cool way of adding
documentation to your product to your
projects
and
to link with what's bebek was asking
before
jupiter book
is
a framework built on top of sphinx
that takes this idea to the next level
so it invites you to write
a lot of documentation in notebooks and
provides a lot of tooling to do that
roshamas asks is gitpod temporary or can
you go back to the same environment in a
week or two
if i recall correctly gitpod pricing
gives me
a few
three hours per month
50 hours per month
and so
yeah
so i think you can go back to it
if you pay if you start paying it's it's
perfect for now
for this tutorial but
[Music]
but yeah you will need to keep paying i
think i don't recall if there are like
options for open source projects or open
source developers or things like that if
anybody
knows a little bit more feel free to
share
okay so i have my
notebook as part of the documentation so
it's a good time to commit let's see
what we have
so i added an extra extension and these
things
i enabled it
in my extensions list
i modified the index to have that
document be part of the talk tree
and i added the notebook itself
i love this div view for notebooks
so i'm going to commit that and say add
tutorial
right
so commit
now
sync
and we're done
okay so i'm going to close the tutorial
i'm not going to do the to do anything
else with it or now
and now
let's go to
[Music]
another of the interesting parts which
is how to
automatically generate
a documentation from code
all right
so
to do that
i'm going to add some extra content here
to the users all right
and this is also in the notes so i'm
going to add another section called
creating
recipes
to create a
recipe
and here comes a very interesting thing
so sphynx has tools to
[Music]
um
document
code objects in several domains
so if you go to the documentation
to the
domains
uh
can you see that
um
making the computer slow
okay um so there are several domains
there's the python domain c c plus
javascript and then naturally restart
the text and that's it and there are
extensions that
allow you to
document
other languages like dot nets or or
things like that
um
so we're going to use just that
and
there's a catch
because this syntax is not supported in
mist
but there is not a problem because
mist allows me to introduce
blocks of rst
so you know if i use this directive
now i can
include any restructured text
code that i want now you don't need to
copy this one because i'm going to
remove it in a moment but this is how i
would document
a
python function so
ingredients
kind equals none and then you would put
here all the
um
the parts
that describe the function behavior so
one line description
return a list of random
ingredients
and then we specify that this has a
parameter
kind
which is an optional
kind argument
this parameter kind has
type
list of strings or non
it returns
the
ingredients
list
and the return type
is again a list of strings
so this is how you would manually
describe a function in sphinx and if i
now go to my documentation back to the
usage page
you see now i get this beautiful
rendering of my documentation so i see
the parameters
the return the return type
and you see it's now mixing the
parameter name
with the parameter return type and the
description
however i told you that i will do away
with this code because
normally we don't want
this because it's much more efficient to
write this in the dog string of the
function oh give me a second
i want to split this
the other way around oh
why
eh
okay so you see uh this is the code that
i showed at the very beginning and it
already has this code and this is valid
restructure text
and
i want to find a way
for
this
dog string here to be part
of the documentation automatically
without having to type it
again
so for that to work
i'm going to do several things first i'm
going to enable another
built-in extension which is called
sphinx x
autodoc
let me see yes
and after i do that
now i
can
remove all this thing
remove the function signature
and instead use the auto function
directive
and now i'm going to go here and you see
that i have exactly
the same result
just to verify that this works since i
installed my library in editable mode
i don't need to reinstall it again every
time i make changes to the code so now
let me add an extra line here like
for now
random list of ingredients
is hard coded
all right
um
the documentation doesn't rebuild
because i didn't make any changes inside
the docs
directory but i forced that
and now you see i get this
for now a random list of ingredients is
hardcoded so sphinx is reading the
python docs string and it's placing that
inside the documentation itself so i
don't need to
write it myself this is as easy as
document your code and then
autodoc will do the rest
okay so let me see
if there's some more questions
what if i need to create hyperlink to my
code documentation
i'm glad you asked
so now how do we generate a hyperlink to
that
so for that we can use another role
you can use the
and now i'm going to put here
the role pi func
specify the name of the function
right let's wait for the rebuild and
you see now this generates
a nice
hyperlink and you notice in fact that
sorry let me go back to usage again when
i click it
this
will be highlighted you see so it's
taking me to these headings here and
again this works in the same way as the
doc and ref
roles that we used before so this is
independent on where the documentation
is hosted
okay so let's finish documenting our
library shall we because we have a
function but we also have
this
invalid kind error
and
that is erased
in some conditions so notice first one
thing
this is already described in the dock
string of the function you see
but notice what happens when i include
that in the documentation
so now
sometimes an error will be raised
and i'm going to use the evolve
rst
directive again
and i'm going to call now the auto
exception
directive with lumaki
invalid
kind error
and now you will notice some magic
happening because not only does this
the dock string of the error
appear here
but
a cross reference from the dock string
is created automatically for me
so if i'm reading the function
documentation then
i can click here you see and this takes
me to the error that is raised
i find this
absolutely
magical
so this is what i did here and in the
same way as before
i can generate an inline
um
cross reference to it by using the pi
exception i think
let me see no i made a mistake here
sorry
i
um
this is not by exception
so this has to be by
x yeah sorry the roles have like a
certain
version of the name sorry about that
yeah
also i made a typo
invalid
kind error
nice so you see now i see
uh cross references to the function and
to the error here
questions
does the automatic creation of the
function documentation also work with
different doctoring formats excellent
question tim
so
there's a sphinx
sphinx extension called napoleon
so napoleon extends the autodoc
capabilities to support two very popular
style guides
the numpy
style guide and the google style guide
so you're probably very familiar with
numpy
um
examples
can i have an example
somewhere yes
you see this is a typical dock string in
numpy that has these parameters the
returns
races see also nodes references whatever
and there's another
style guide that i have actually never
used which is
by google
and it's like a similar idea but with
different markup you see so this arcs
returns and so forth so napoleon
allows you to use this kind of dog
strings
on your project i'm going to share the
link
must the race exception ever be part of
a class
for this link to work i
don't
get the question sorry jeremy if you
want if you can rephrase a little bit
um
i don't remember i don't in the study do
you refer to the
dog string here or to the market that
i'm adding here so i'm going to jump to
the next question in the meanwhile
do we need to list all functions classes
and error
one by one or can we add all as a list
from a file that's another excellent
question we're not going to do that
today because we don't have enough time
but
there's
an
an extension called auto summary
in sphinx that that's exactly that
it is an automatic
summary of all your documentation so
again i'm going to share the link here
and there's another one
that works in a slightly different way
but does the same thing which is
sphinx dash dash auto api which is in
our github organization but it's
maintained by the community
auto summary imports the code
sphinx auto api parses the code
so
they work in slightly different ways
um
i'm more used to auto api these days
because it's more convenient but
they are mostly the same
um
okay
so it's another good moment to
commit these changes please so let's
review what we
have i added an extra line to the dock
string so i could see the changes
i enabled the auto dock
built-in sphinx extension so i can add
cross references
to
sorry so i can automatically generate
um documentation from the code
and i added a bunch of
content to the usage including crash
references
code objects
and so forth so i'm going to say
document
python
code
commit
sync
and there we go
okay we are
reaching the end of the tutorial which
makes me enormously happy because that
means that we will have some time to
chat
at the end or to do some extra stuff
perhaps
so now it's the time to deploy this
documentation
and so far i've been using like this
gitpod thing that is very convenient
um
but gitbot is not permanent and this is
using the python http server which
is not necessarily a production solution
and so there are several options to
deploy this code
so
you have several
providers of static documentation that
you can use like netlify or github pages
things like that
but instead we're going to use redox
because it allows us to do some extra
stuff so redetox rather than
hosting the html it's going to build the
html for us
and it will also give me like versions
server-side search
and
and many other things
so now i'm going to change
the platform for a moment
let me
this is my fork yes and these are my
commits so everything looks nice
online
um
if you want
uh to try this
or to have a look at
my progress so far you have this
but this is temporary anyway so the one
that is going to stay is the original
repository and i created a branch
called tutorial steps
where you have
like how all the project looks like at
the end
in case you got lost or you want to go
over this again or anything like that
so now it's time to open greet the docs
and i already have an account here
and otherwise you can sign up with
github is really quick
and what i'm going to do is import these
documentation projects
in my account
so
i'm going to go here to my dashboard and
click this import project button
and it's very important to refresh this
list of repositories because now it says
that i don't have any repositories but
in fact if i refresh
this lumac one will appear here
if this fails for some reason then you
could import manually but doing it this
way has a bunch of advantages
so i'm going to import it
i'm going to call it lumaki
by data
tutorial
whatever so the name is taken sorry
you cannot use it
and and all the rest of the options are
okay so this is the url of the
repository it's git
and default branch is main so let me hit
next
and now the project is created and right
at the after it's created
is going to try and build the
documentation
so now i'm going to go to the builds
section here
it also says what hook
successfully added which means that
every time i push a new commit of my
project it's going to trigger a new
build so let me see how this looks like
this is triggered already
and
come on
i guess like if some people are
following along
along
and
we perhaps are overwhelming the servers
but i hope that that is not the case
and anyway like this
this we need a few seconds
to to trigger anyway
um
in the meanwhile to not be here like
looking at this
spinner i'm going to advance that
this build is going to fail okay it's
already cloning the project perfect
so this build is going to fail because
we are not telling read the docs
how to
install our code or what dependencies
does it need or anything like that so
it's going to make to try to make a
guess
of
how to build it you see that by default
it uses python 37 we're going to change
that now
by clicking on this elements here you
can see the logs
and finally this failed you see this was
doing rather than doing make html it was
calling these things package directly
but the result is the same
and it failed very early saying no
module named
missed parser so i need to tell read the
docs that it has to
install the code
and for that i'm going to go back to git
pod
and i'm going to create a new file
which i will call dot read the docs dot
yaml
has to be called exactly like this
it's again in the notes but i'm going to
share it in the chat just in case
and i need to add some configuration
here so i know this
by heart and i also have some notes
but you can check the documentation for
this
online so you have some examples or
valid configurations
here i'm going to share this url with
you as well
if you can ask a question on this step
with your microphone yeah reshama of
course i need yourself feel free
hi
can you hear me okay
uh
very very low very low okay um
i'll try to speak up um the question
that i had to ask was and i don't know
if you covered it but can this also be
hosted on
github pages
yes so the workflow is slightly
different
um
on read the docs
uh
all the build process is taking care so
you don't have to
define like a file that says okay do
make html in this step and so on so
forth
and
however the downside of that is that you
have a little bit less flexibility on
the process so you have like a super
weird documentation pipeline or you have
to run some commands or some things like
that
there are hacky ways to to do that
but no it's not officially supported
like you can add some some process calls
to comfort.pie but i mean it works it's
just really ugly
and so the way you would do this with
github pages
is that you will have to
[Music]
import like uh github action
or things like that that build
documentation for you and then
store the
html files as as an artifact
um
so yeah that would be the the difference
however there are some things that are a
little bit difficult to replicate on
github pages for example
um
like if i go to the documentation
of
my open source astrodynamics library
and that is also hosted on 3d docs you
see that there's
several versions here so i have another
one which is 0.14
0.15 which is the latest one and so
forth so this sort of
multiple build
uh sorry multiple version documentation
is really handy and it's very easy to
set up on 3d docs it just uses github
branches for that
and
there are other things like the server
side search that is
enhanced
so for example if i go back to
my the documentation of redox itself and
i start typing here you see i have this
search as you type
and this is going to make a search and
so forth so there's like
a few things on top of just starting
files uh hosting that's the thing
having said that yes you can host
sphinx output in github pages if you
want but you miss all these extra
features
okay thanks see i just wanted to because
i just went through the process and i
hosted my project on read the docs and i
did some research and it it sort of it
just clicked in my mind like oh i need
to i can run the docs locally but then i
have to find a way to host them right
and i i think initially i didn't make
that connection and the fact that there
are there's github pages option and read
the docs but read the docs has more
options like in terms of search and
such
yeah okay
okay yeah thank you very much um
we're almost at the end so at this point
if someone else has any questions let's
say
[Music]
let's put that at the end
so i was saying that i need to define
a
configuration file now to tell read the
docs what to do
and
i share with you the
the documentation for that but i'm going
to copy that
from my notes so i have to specify what
is the version of the configuration
uh usually version two there's no point
in using version one anymore it's
deprecated
now this is a thing that we introduced
like two weeks ago so we specified that
the docker image is going to be based on
ubuntu
2004
this doesn't mean that it's using the
docker image of ubuntu
of this version of ubuntu it means that
we have our own docker image that has
this operative system as the baseline
and now i'm going to specify that i want
some extra tools and in particular i
want python 3.9 okay i
don't want to jump into 310 just yet
and because i don't remember if
sphinx
is already compatible with it so i don't
want any breakage let's stay with 39 for
the moment
now i need to specify that the sphinx
configuration leaves
in dox slash source slash
conf.buy and finally i need to specify
that to build the documentation you need
to do this step that i did before you
see this pip install minus e dot
doc
so the way to say that is by saying that
i need to install some python code
with
pip
it's going to be the current directory
so this path here and i'm going to add
the extra
requirements
coming from the
dock
optional dependencies
okay so unless i made some mistake i
think this is correct
um i need to commit and push for this to
work so i'm going to go here
the only change is adding the
documentation fine that looks good
so i'm going to say add
read the docs configuration
yes i want to commit yes i want to sync
okay and
since i have a new commit here you see
this one 12 seconds ago
now if i go back to beat the dogs to the
builds page
you see now there's another build that
got triggered
there is now installing the code and you
will notice that instead of using the
three seven python three seven that was
using before
now it's using python three nine we do
that through a tool it's called asdf
which is like a like pie m but it also
works for node and go
and
know go and rust
all right so you can install all those
tools on three detox as well in case you
need like to build some front-end assets
or something like that
and now this is
installing some base dependencies
this should be quick so let's give it
some seconds
mario jose religious tutorial thank you
very much
and bram as well thank you for the
workshop i'm glad that you're enjoying
it let's see the final result
so
it's installing some data dependencies
and now you see it's doing the pip
install
dot dock
so this installs
lumaki but also furo mb sphinx miss
parser and all of that
and it's already finished so if i now go
to viewdocs
i have
my
lumaki documentation in all its glory
with
the usage
the cross references working
the tutorial that is working here as
well
and so forth here i have the flyout menu
in case i want to specify
some extra versions
or things like that
and that's it
that's about it i
[Music]
really happy that everything worked more
or less first time so now
let me
finish and wrap up
going back to my
slides
so
as i shared in slack and here in the
chat
these slides and all the material of the
tutorial is online so you can check it
out if you see an issue or have a
suggestion please talk to me open an
issue there let's discuss
um
parts of this are based on the missed
introduction that is very cool
this is the sphinx tutorial that i am
writing in collaboration with the
community sphinx was lacking a tutorial
for many years
and
now it's very complete
it basically covers all the steps that
we did today and some more however it's
written in restructure text
and you also have our
free detox tutorial that i also wrote in
coming months and and it covers things
like how to
import your project how to customize
your build process how to add versions
to your documentation and so forth so
you have all this information here
and if you want to reach out to me i'll
be
around for the rest of the conference i
will try to attend some networking in
gather town
you can drop me an email and i'm usually
most active
on linkedin and
twitter
so thank you very much
and i think i can take some extra
questions from the audience
so donnie says is rtd always open to the
public for instance if i want to
document a company internal tool could i
use rtd with a login
yes
thanks for asking so for that you would
use readthedocs.com
instead which is our commercial offering
and it gives you
some extra features in particular you
can have private
projects and you have more resources and
and things like that so if you're
interested uh
drop us an email
thank you very much
thank you very much
rather one
good to see